estos migrantes no saben si quedarse en
el cruce fronterizo registrarse en línea
o ir a un consulado la confusión reina
de la frontera norte de México con
Estados Unidos prácticamente como que si
le rompieran los sueños a uno porque uno
viene con una meta con ganas de ayudar a
la familia y pues
no salen con esto por orden de un juez
Federal de Washington este miércoles
vencía el título 42 una normativa de
salud pública promovida en 2020 durante
la administración Trump para detener el
flujo de migrantes y frenar la
propagación del covid 19 sin embargo los
fiscales de 19 estados conservadores
reclamaron al tribunal supremo que
mantuviera la regla el alto tribunal los
escuchó y los límites pandémicos al
ingreso de migrantes seguirán vigentes
al menos por ahora lo que estamos viendo
aquí ahorita es una situación de Limbo
hay muchas personas migrantes que están
en Ciudad Juárez que están a las
comunidades norteñas de México esperando
este nuevo tropiezo para Joe biden ha
sido aprovechado por sus detractores
republicanos quienes consideran que
mantener el título 42 ayudaría a detener
la ola de inmigración ilegal y que por
el contrario su eliminación llevaría a
un aumento de los cruces irregulares por
lo que piden detener el que califican
como un continuo fracaso en las
políticas migratorias de la Casa Blanca
Cómo funcionará el título 42 a partir de
hoy nadie sabe con certeza Mientras
tanto miles de migrantes continúan
apostados del lado mexicano de la
frontera a la espera de conocer una
decisión definitiva sobre la medida que
desde su promulgación en marzo de 2020
ha permitido la expulsión acelerada de
más de 2,7 millones de personas